welcome to this new video yeah I'm
trying a new session here last one I
also had to stop it was so terrible and
before I started this one I lost the
warm-up game which was unspeakable at
the moment I feel like I would total
[ __ ] why not playing a GM with her with
same bad rating as mine come on let's
get rid of this this is Bosnia right
tokelau Bosnia no I'm sorry Bosnia has
this the same thing about whether this
is sorry this was the wrong orientation
of this of this triangle this irritated
me okay a classical Kings Indian let's
see with night with 92 unbeliever at the
moment and yeah I have no idea about
this opening maybe I'm already doing
something wrong it feels like white is
very quick now right okay maybe I'm I
can still get in some some counter play
okay all night f-for he will probably
also drop back to f1 if I take now night
x puts lots of pressure on d6 how bad is
it to switch back to the f4 plan f4 and
rook f6 to cover d6 and then maybe g5
rook h6 person completely completely
moronic probably but ok let's see ya
yeah okay it's clear that why this much
better on the queenside we know that but
maybe I can still get something going
here Nigeria sometimes
ok I feel fear ok it wasn't forced to
retreat that's good news for him I get
some night to be six that's not good
night to be six or maybe he wants to
sacrifice here I don't know now i don't
i don't think that 95 can be can be that
great maybe maybe okay but cannot i
cannot attend to that i need some some
sort of play here battling on did some
based on on tricks here anyway so g4
maybe and then Knight f6 on
him then g-form pretty much whatever he
does a pledge reform yeah the whole the
whole quince practice of course gone it
is also Knight b6 all the time not sure
about that move what exactly is it doing
queen bee eight maybe okay i'm playing
this anyway okay i can take c6 and t4
now taking you for immediately runs into
27 okay but then i can take f2 maybe
maybe i can do that ok let's let's let's
grab no I just I just recognized that
after night f2s 96 intermediate move but
Knight f6 okay maybe go here 98 coming
possibly a queen d8 coming yeah the B
part is very strong of course and this
is a cause for concern Giacomo I need I
need some some direct play here Knight
f6 I have this check on g form i-94 e
for it's not working
Knight f6 Queen d8 this is really really
annoying this as possible and I cannot
avoid the Queen trade after that
hmm there's some way to avoid it may be
look here 28 my I cannot play queen of
seven right time morning
and again you for it's not possible
the all-night f7 is Sam is really really
bad that this is also coming
yeah and I g6 mm okay come on black
resigns I'm not sure maybe I had some
some chances on the King there an
objectively blackness of course lost but
i wasn't i will ensure if there are some
tricks but there is nothing yeah that's
absolutely nothing I'm I'm just too too
bad on the queenside this means that f4
is probably probably not not really
playable my queen side is to weaken and
this is most like that are important of
course I've meaning if it gives me some
time by retreating to c3 that that might
still be be be playable in a way I can
maybe organize look aged 69 f 6 or rope
gee 69 f 64 let's take some time but
after this I'm basically forced to
enforce to keep my bishop p.m. and NT
I'm losing really it's it's too quick
it's too too quick on the queenside it's
also the B porn in addition yeah I has
also bit unlucky if you if you have
wrecked your rating like that then he
hit you impaired with the Grand Master
but this is bed rating but it it costs
lots of points okay thanks for watching